[Music]
welcome to the optimism company
I imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do and that's why I
created the optimism company our company
is devoted to helping you build your
human skills and it turns out when we
become great human beings we become
better Partners better employees better
spouses better parents so what
specifically does the optimism company
do well we have virtual and in-person
workshops Keynotes and private classes
that you can bring to your business and
we have courses live online classes and
an ever-growing video library that any
individual can access at any time and
all of those things are pieces of the
puzzle that we all need to be better
human beings take care of yourself and
take care of each other
foreign